trump fox news contributor joins us
right now
laura good morning to you good morning
good morning guys by the way uh another
stat on charlotte it is four hours away
from my hometown of wilmington north
carolina in case anyone wanted there you
go
that's where you went to go shopping
right when you were a young girl
you still are young we went to raleigh
where we went to charlotte yeah yep we
did too it's great to have you uh
yesterday at the white house our
correspondent asked jen saki about
something that your father-in-law did a
number of times and that is go to our
southern border but it wasn't about when
was the last time
it was a little more expansive and the
answer is shocking watch this
as president biden ever been to the
southern border
in his life yes i will have to get look
back in my history books and check the
times he's been to the southern we have
been looking all morning and we cannot
find any record of him visiting the
border as president vice president
senator or even as a concerned citizen
why would that be
i can check and see when the last time
or when he may have been but but tell me
more about why you're asking because
this is a president who makes a point
when there are disasters in this country
like a wildfire or
a hurricane to go and see for himself
firsthand
what the needs are of the local
community so that he can have an
informed
pov to make policy why doesn't he do
that why doesn't he go down to del rio
texas and see what's going on well first
of all peter i think the situation at
the border is the result of a broken
system and the president certainly
relies on his experience
so laura yesterday uh peter in our brain
room look for hours could not find any
record of joe biden
ever being at the u.s mexican border
can i just say that i'm so glad that we
have peter ducey at the white house
asking real questions and these aren't
they shouldn't be tough questions by the
way these are very straightforward
questions that should be easy to answer
uh but it seems to give the press
secretary there a real hard time when
he's there we're very fortunate to have
him asking actual questions uh but you
heard jinsaki there dare i say did she
slip up guys and perhaps tell the truth
that joe biden is actually relying on
his experience here his five decades of
doing just about nothing for the
american people and applying it to the
southern border i think that's pretty
accurate he's doing nothing down there
you would think to peter's point if you
have a complete crisis at hand whether
it's wildfires whether it's hurricanes
whether it's mass shootings whatever it
might be the president of the united
states
always goes to those areas and and as he
referenced talks to the local community
and says what do you need how can we
help joe biden is completely absent in
this scenario
but maybe there is a more sinister
reason maybe it is because this is all
purposeful maybe it is because they want
these millions of illegal immigrants
pouring into our country perhaps these
are the future voters for the democrat
party the united states of america is
incredibly disenfranchised with what we
have seen in the first eight months of
the biden presidency so you have to ask
yourself is there a bigger reason he
hasn't even bothered to go down there
maybe they want it to happen the closest
we could find was guatemala in 2014 to
address root causes sound familiar yeah
right brian yeah just the new york times
today they said when he was drawing up
his immigration policies officials in
his uh cabinet uh were saying maybe you
should hold on to the trump policy known
as remaining mexico at which time they
decided he decided not to do that
because trump had become so toxic
so rather than solve the problem he
wanted to play politics it sounds
exactly like afghanistan
it sounds exactly like afghanistan and
yet we have a solution it is to do what
donald trump did because that was
working finish the wall we saw that they
had to build basically a wall with
vehicles down there to to stop people
from coming over the border walls work
we know that finish building the wall
keep the remaining mexico policy
reimplement the policies that the trump
administration had put in because they
were working but joe biden couldn't help
himself he had to do away with every
single thing that donald trump had put
in place so i i you're right brian it is
it's preposterous to see this happen in
america that this guy would rather play
politics than protect the american
people but sadly that is what we have on
our hands right now with joe biden as
president i know when your father-in-law
was president he was uh pro-israel and
supported the iron dome which has saved
the lives of so many israelis we
normally contribute to the iron dome and
we were supposed to give one billion
dollars for that defense system and the
funding was removed on tuesday from this
uh government funding package after a
lot of pressure from the squad there is
now a democrat from connecticut
congresswoman rosa delaro she's the
house appropriations chair she she wants
that funding put back in place and she
is introducing a new bill she says the
united states commitment to the security
of our friend and ally israel is
ironclad replenishing interceptors used
to protect israel from attacks is our
legal and moral responsibility while
this funding would ordinarily be
included in a year-end spending package
we are advancing this legislation now to
demonstrate congress's bipartisan
commitment to israel's security as part
of a middle east
as part of a middle east with lasting
peace so why do you think the squad is
against giving israel this money which
protects their people
well sadly ainsley they've shown that
they they hate israel they have not made
any bones about it every way possible
they have shown their anti-semitism at
every single turn
and it's horrible to see israel is our
middle eastern ally uh they are the only
free nation in the middle east and gosh
we ought to protect them we ought to
want uh to protect that country and we
always have but i think the scariest
part of this is if you ever wondered who
was actually in control of the democrat
party if these women could take one
billion dollars and make it zero dollars
basically in the matter of hours
that's your answer these are the people
running the democrat party it was not
hyperbole when we suggested that there
were socialists running the democrat
party it is these women and here is your
proof and that is a really scary thing
for the future of america if decisions
like this can be made by a very small
group of people who do not represent the
average american who whose values are
far outside of the bounds of anything uh
you know that we have ever considered
american what does that say for the
future of our country if these are the
people now in charge yeah
listen
mac miller who is running for lieutenant
governor of the great state of nevada
went to the people in charge of clark
county in nevada and he wanted to speak
on behalf you know his point of view uh
they were talking about covet and all
sorts of things there he is being
dragged out of the meeting
they rammed him into i'm sure it was
accidental but nonetheless they threw
him through a metal detector here he is
talking about
what happened and what he thinks
why it happened here he is mac miller
the county commission meetings are
supposed to be
run by the commissioners for the people
of clark county here in nevada and those
people have a right to ask questions and
be interested in what's on the agenda at
these meetings and what was on the
agenda at this meeting
was a proclamation to basically do away
with nevada's clark county's first
amendment rights and i was there to
witness and oppose
this proclamation and that didn't get to
happen uh because i was attacked after
trying to defend the people in this
county they will never stop me mac
miller from being able to defend them
and they'll never prevent me from coming
out to defend the people of this great
state of nevada
and laura at that particular meeting the
final vote was five to two where the
committee declared that spreading
covid19 misinformation is a public
health crisis he wanted to speak out but
obviously and perhaps it was because he
was a republican not allowed and that's
what he was talking about
yeah any dissenting opinion um we'll
we'll get this this is what will happen
to i mean basically where we're headed
in america right now under democrat
control is that if your opinion does not
directly align with theirs and you are
not putting information out that they
agree with then you are silenced your
first amendment right is immediately
taken away you saw it happen here what a
terrible scene
to see this shouldn't happen
in the united states of america and i
think it's it's very very frightening
that this has happened so quickly here
what happened to public discourse what
happened to us sharing opinions and we
can all gain from that that used to be
the way of things that i would share my
opinion and you could share yours and we
could learn from one another but now
that is over those days are gone now
unless your views as i said align
directly with what the democrats and big
tech want to have out there you are
silenced on social media you are kicked
out of uh meetings like this and we see
it happen time and time again it's
terrible yeah the pres you remember the
president said his patience is wearing
thin with the american people so we're
getting on his nerves a little bit we
see also it's great our allies really
feel welcomed uh france just recalled
their ambassador and israel was left
naked in front of hamas uh thanks to the
democratic party it's a great message
laura thanks so much
thanks guys have a great day